[Musique]
nous devons nous retrousser les manches
parce qu'il faut sauver des vies et
sauver l'activité économique
le couvre-feu est aujourd'hui la seule
réponse crédible
est ce que c'est une bonne solution sur
le fond je pense que je veux je pense
qu'il n'a pas le choix en fait il faut
regarder l'évidence en face quand les
quartiers on va dire dits sensibles où
la police n'est pas toujours la
bienvenue
ça sera très très compliqué de faire
respecter un couvre-feu pourquoi parce
qu'on n'a pas les effectifs nécessaires
pour appréhender l'ensemble des
quartiers
en même temps on vous a connu plus
rebelle en face à des décisions de
l'état
oui oui mais je suis pour salah défaut
bien des fois je pense que c'est injuste
donc je me bats quand je pense que c'est
pour l'intérêt général je soutiens cette
punition collective
c'est finalement la réponse d'un
gouvernement qui n'a eu aucune stratégie
aucune capacité d'anticiper et puis de
mettre de mener à bien sa fameuse
politique de tracer tester isolé il y
aura un temps pour le bilan le bilan
critique
il faudra quand même se poser la
question des choix politiques comment on
en est arrivé là il y aura pas un
policier derrière chaque français
d'ailleurs y en a jamais eu depuis début
de cette crise pourquoi parce que c'est
ce que le président de la république a
rappelé hier c'est aussi sur la
responsabilité individuelle des français
qu'on parie qu'on investit 12 mille
policiers et gendarmes sont chaque nuit
entre 21h et 6h spécialement chargé de
faire vérifier effectivement les
interdictions évoqué par monsieur le
premier ministre
plus tous les agents de police et de
gendarmerie qui travaille naturellement
à la sécurité des français et donc va
s'ajouter à eux cette nouvelle mission
de devoir contrôler ce couvre-feu je
pense que nous allons avoir encore
d'autres débordements et que les forces
de sécurité qui sont déjà violemment
attaqué ça va se poursuivre une
autorisation selon les mots du président
sera nécessaire pour circuler entre 21h
et 6h du matin en cas d'urgence médicale
les déplacements seront aussi autorisés
attention en revanche si vous n'avez pas
de raison valable pour circuler vous
serez passible d'une amende de 135 euros
1500 euros en cas de récidive il faut
que les contrôles qu'ils soient faits
dans la rue soit fait avec bienveillance
parce que s'il ya trop de répression il
y aura de la rébellion
et si à la guerre il faut payer les
soldats et les soldats ce sont les
soignants jérôme salomon le directeur
général de la santé devait être l'invité
de jean-jacques bourdin ce matin il a
été victime d'un problème personnel de
dernière minute
on nous a dit que il serait tombé chez
lui je ne sais pas si c'est bon je pense
que c'est vrai enfin on ne va pas nous
inventer nous inventer une raison comme
celle-là c'est dans ce contexte que des
perquisitions en série ont eu lieu ce
matin au domicile et les bureaux du
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand et
du directeur général de la santé jérôme
salomon même chose pour l'ancien premier
ministre edouard philippe et d'anciens
membres du gouvernement agnès buzyn et
si mme ndiaye cette perquisition s'est
déroulée dans les conditions normales à
la fois avec beaucoup de minutie de la
part de ceux qui procédait dans une
atmosphère poli et courtoise
la justice est saisie elle travaille
sereinement
moi aussi la cour de justice de la
république avait en effet ouvert en
juillet dernier une information
judiciaire à la suite de plaintes
déposées notamment par des médecins
mettant en cause la gestion de la crise
sanitaire par le gouvernement
confiance que j'accorde à monsieur
olivier vérins ici présents sachez
qu'elle est totale outre bien entendu à
ce besoin de rappeler que sur le volet
judiciaire que je ne connais pas il
bénéficie d'une totale présomption
d'innocence
il ya un grand vide dans ces annonces
c'est ce qui concerne l'hôpital c'est
celle ce sont les soignants donc le
bilan de ce gouvernement dans la gestion
de la crise c'est qu'on a moins de
personnel moins de moyens à l'hôpital
aujourd'hui ont géré la crise qu'au mois
de janvier à dire avant le premier pic
donc il ya bien effectivement une
défaillance de ce gouvernement
matin midi soir la nuit le week-end un
test devant vous il est toujours au
front toujours au front toujours